well also in New York we talked to Garth
Brooks about his big adventure
he performed there for the first time in
nearly 20 years and our Jennifer Paris
was backstage with Garth and his wife
Chrissy Yearwood
why was Yankee Stadium the perfect place
for you to come back you know what we
didn't have New York on the world tour
schedule because how do you come back
from Central Park isn't really true that
he was pacing back before last night
nervous and jittery oh yeah yeah yeah
he's a pacer anyway he doesn't sit birth
is the first country music act to ever
perform in Yankee Stadium but we were
with Garth back in 1997 when he
performed in another famous place in New
York City Central Park hey you know if
we've got desires and people show up
great they did show up nearly a million
people jammed Central Park my job
anywhere I go is to make no matter what
size the room as small as I can it was
so big and it happened so fast you don't
remember a lot of it it was such a blur
I've never seen that many people in my
life I just remember how beautiful the
weather was beautiful weather knocked
the case this weekend though where rain
seemed to play along with the Thunder
roll singer
one things that mirrors the weather you
know so everything's on a ramp here so
if it rains oh that's not good
the fans didn't seem to mind though
everybody's still saying along
and you can sing along with Garth on his
upcoming Sirius XM channel no doubt
you're gonna hear Garth's new album when
it arrives in the fall as the tour
starts to wind down this radio channel
will start to kind of take over so I'm
hoping they're prepared for a long haul
because how about this tonight on
Facebook Garth is launching insights
geot of Monday night conversation and
you want to check it out because every
week Garth is giving fans a live look at
the creation of his new album meanwhile
Kevin Frazier just got a look in